um
[Music]
i miss getting ready for games and
preparing for games you know you know
what we do is uh
we have the best jobs in the world you
know doing your passion for a living so
when it ends like that
you start thinking about all the the
whole year so
um
give credit to the celtics first off man
their incredible team they got a chance
to do some big things the rest of the
playoffs and
they played amazing
not that you need any extra motivation
but the seasoning the way that it it did
the east is getting stronger the league
in general young players are stepping up
how much fuel does this add or how
unique is the fuel being added to your
fire right now i mean
i just focus on me i mean
i see what's going on around the league
i mean everybody's it's a great time to
be in our leagues a lot of talent a lot
of skill but
at the end of the day just focus on
being the best that i can be and adding
it to the group wherever whatever the
group is um
you know but the league has grown fast
and so many great players and we got to
be right there you know
with the pack if we want to be a
contending team so we got a lot of work
to do
kevin when you look at a series that was
as lopsided as this was do you look at
boston and just say hey that's a team
that's
they're younger they're longer they're
more athletic and look at it as a
physical thing or do you look at this
and say
we weren't together long enough we
weren't together enough on the court we
didn't have the cohesion we needed and
this is on us i mean we can all just we
got a lot of stuff that may factor into
why we lose but like they were just a
better team
i mean they're just a better team i mean
we
they played that way you know we uh
this is the best defense in the league
right i mean for
most of the series we i mean the whole
series we shot over 50
40 from the three
but turnovers offensive rebounds
straight line drives really killed us
you know standing in front of their guys
and bigger guys that you know we look up
and
seth curry or draggage is boxing out at
seven foot are they playing hard but
they're just smaller you know and a lot
of bigs out on the perimeter on the
swiss guard in the guard you know so
there's a lot of stuff that happened
throughout the series that just didn't
work in our favor and
but i like the way um
we tried to come together towards the
end of the season and
saw visual was lost you know with guys
being injured guys being traded just you
know so once we finally got together we
had a mission and wanted to make the
playoffs and see what kind of noise we
could make and
we didn't make any noise but we got to
the playoff
kevin obviously this is gonna be the
last time we talked to you until the
beginning of next season i mean when you
look at the guys that you have on the
roster for next season it's you kai ben
joe seth patty
probably nick or bruce i mean what do
you think about that roster going
forward and then after this series what
do you guys what do you think that you
guys maybe need to add to that roster to
be able to
compete christian you know it's we just
got done playing
but
you know i don't i don't know the
answers to those questions to that
question right now i mean
isn't it isn't bruce free agent
isn't patti a free agent too
i don't know i don't know the situation
is with the contracts or who we you know
i just don't know and i mean
obviously when losing in playoffs you're
looking forward to next year and seeing
we could be on the team you know there's
a lot of high expectations around the
net so people want to have some hope of
what may happen in the future but at
this point
two hours an hour after the game
it's hard for me to say um i'm sure
you'll get some info here in the next
few weeks or next month or so
with
draft coming up in june you know so it's
right around the corner
kevin if you look at this year and even
if you want to go back to list you mean
just how many of you guys problems do
you think stem from the injuries and the
attrition and and the lack of continuity
versus some of the stuff you're saying
like the personnel and the the size
issues and whatnot
yeah i wish we were more healthy as a
group
i wish we had more continuity as a group
but that's just the league that's just
every team goes through that
you know
you can
definitely
use those things as a
you know just to gauge what kind of team
we had and
the reason why we lost games but
um i mean it's hard to
pinpoint just one or two things i think
you know
it's a lot of stuff that happened
throughout the season i needed me
that you need to go well in order for
you to be a good team and
a lot of things didn't go our way
kevin expectations were high this year
does that make this loss more difficult
to
[Music]
i
absorb
man it's tough to lose i mean end of
your season i mean we love
doing what we do
you know so not being able to get up and
go to the gym every day is going to be
a shock for us the first few weeks and
then we're going to go enjoy our summer
keep getting better and
do this whole thing again it's a real
it's a cycle you know for us so um
you know we had our expectations
everybody had expectations for us a lot
of stuff happened throughout the season
that derailed us
but i'm proud of how we just kept
fighting and kept you know keeping the
faith and every day was trying to work
towards something you know you could
take that away from the season
with those expectations and stuff i'm
sure losing always hurts but when you
had
you know you and kyrie and james hard
and
is there almost a little extra regret
that you don't see something like that
very often what you guys had put
together and you just didn't capitalize
on it
no regrets
i mean
[ __ ] happens
you know
no crying over spilled meal it's about
how we can progress and get better from
here i mean we see and we've been
through
you know a lot this year everybody in
the organization knows what we went
through you know so no need no time i
feel regret or
be too pissed off about how can we find
solutions to get better
proactive
as an organization to get better even
the great teams they don't dwell on what
they do they just try to continue to
keep getting better
so for us we know we where our mistakes
were we just try to
you know make tournaments and strengths
um but we can't handle regrets on what
we did [ __ ] just played out the way it
played
kevin to that point
how much of
all the things that you guys dealt with
off the floor impacted
the team and the product on it
guys were in and out the lineup we
injured
[Music]
seth came over with a little ankle
injury so he was in and out the lineup
gorham had got
co-head at the wrong time kyrie is not
the lineup
i was gone for six months i mean that
hurts any team
not having your main guys out on the
floor
and that's tough for any coaching staff
to
build continuity or
build a
chemistry or system around your players
when they are in the lineup so everybody
had to
step outside of their normal roles as
players as coaches as executives to do
some stuff
to kind of
mask what was going on with our with our
organization i think
it's a great effort by everybody to try
to like i said
you know bring this thing together and
do something special um
but
a lot of stuff out of people's control
um that happened this year
but we still put ourselves
gave ourselves opportunity to compete
for a championship by being in the
playoffs so
you know it was uh
once the regular season ended and once
the playoffs started it was good it was
cool to kind of reset and start over you
get what i'm saying so
this summers will be a very very
important summer for our organization
and we'll see where we go next year
just to be clear do you think that steve
is still the right guy to lead this
group
i mean
come on man like
yeah like
steve has been dealt a crazy hand the
last two years
right you've been had to deal with so
much stuff as a head coach first time
coaching
trades injuries
you know covey just a lot of stuff he
had to deal with you know i'm proud of
how he just focus and his passion
for us and um
you know we all
you know continue to keep developing
over the summer and see what happens
katie um how much is the past year of
everything that you've gone through as a
player olympics this season taking a
physical and emotional toll on you and
secondly
do you plan on having input with
personnel decisions as the franchise
player
uh know uh
no i felt great this year i feel like
the extra minutes for the olympics did
anything i felt
i felt amazing this whole season
physically was outside of my mcl
um
[Music]
but i feel fatigued i didn't feel
i didn't feel any of that
[Music]
and yeah of course i mean i want to know
who i'm playing without on the floor you
know i want to know
[Music]
what we're thinking i mean sean in the
front office all of us we just talk
basketball regardless because we enjoy
basketball so sometimes our team may
come up and what we may need and what i
see
from a player's perspective we always
had conversations that's what makes
great organizations